and welcome to punch-drunk sports we are
back in the studio super excited with a
lot of construction going on or
somebody's got a crotch rocket out
tonight as a dentist next door there's a
do some serious drilling guys I hope you
guys had a great Memorial Day weekend
joining us in studio he's got a great
podcast called IMF's problem-solving
with david dairy an executive producer
Sam Tripoli my good friend David Deary
what about hold on one second are we
hearing this what are they doing what do
the show I do to show why I got drilling
in my ears guys Dave why don't you tell
us a little bit about your podcast
oh it's basic premise I just solve
people's problems me being gifted
I've been gifted with just the
relentless ability to help people you
know I'm a selfless person and I've
decided that uh it's just good to give
back to the community I'm ready go on
tell us about your great podcast that's
it I just solve people's problems they
write into me give me an example
yeah give me a problem it can be I mean
seriously I've been having a lot of
daymares away koror what you're wearing
yeah awake so you have anxiety you call
it anxiety more like living nightmares
living nightmares I'm realistic or in
your in your mind you can go both ways
yeah both like geez I mean narrow it
help me out here how are you help you um
help me help you I feel like everyone's
out to get me first off okay this is
what I tell people when you give someone
a problem I need as many details as
possible yeah I need as many details as
possible so I can solve all your
problems but it's like don't just keep
them on me it's like
I'd be more specific I can't stop
[ __ ] dummies like that's fine that is
that a problem yeah why is that problem
that's Mary
you saw wow that's an amazing your
problem you're good that's really good
your problem is that you think [ __ ]
dummies is a problem but you know maybe
other people will judge you but not
dummies are you talking like crash-test
dummies ah mannequin I assumed man is
for jerks are you know no mannequins
that's fine that's fine I call them
women Akins original sex that non-binary
Akins yeah yeah you're in there's no
problem I think a lot of the problems
that I saw aren't really problems and
then that's a lot of it is it makes it
easy to solve that's very easy you just
be like that's not a problem you solved
anybody's problem and then it didn't
work out and then they killed themselves
I'm not sure because the podcast is
pretty new and so uh it doesn't get to
that well I hope it doesn't either and
if it does I hope I don't find out
that's yeah you don't want gravity your
listeners by often them but no your fun
thing is if their phone yeah their phone
is still active then I guess I'll still
have that subscription but yeah that's
what's important so it's a big deal but
it's available on iTunes and everything
else it's available on iTunes and Google
Play and I guess I think stitcher I
don't really know much about that then
you're the executive producer make it
happen yeah I did I got on all those Oh
Jason where you gonna be
I got a couple dates I'm gonna be
getting my teeth fixed next door at the
new dental places apparently there I'll
be at the store this week I got two
times I'll be at the story this week
Saturday we have our big fight companion
at Sycamore tavern ah yeah yeah that'll
be fun so come to that's going to Sam
Mickey go fight mommy and myself
watching the big UFC on the 4th moon of
Taurus I'm gonna be and I'm seeing at
the March of Dimes bags and Long Beach
I'll be selling pot to sick children I
love that's gonna be good its
problem-solving right there yeah one
hand washes the other so if you're a
sick child and you have ten bucks come
on down and get some pot and I'm gonna
be at the Queen Mary Dairy Queen serving
ice cream for the vets of the Civil War
oh that's awesome that's awesome
Davi Yanni gig
this Wednesday I'll be at Pizza nice the
long beach we're starting a monthly show
there Chloe you love doing shows where
they serve pizza I like the only shows
where it's just weird because comedy
club Booker's don't book me so [ __ ]
thanks for bringing that up [ __ ] lice
why why here's a problem solving here's
the problem why don't you play like taco
trucks I do yeah I play bike shops taco
trucks panty stores thrift stores
funerals
I would I would that funeral home would
actually be one of the best places to do
a comedy show hey bro I think you just
put them right in the right in the Cask
a casket shop would be a better Cemetery
I give you bomb is an open casket on the
stage you have to go lay enough ah the
next comic comes up are it's perfect
this Friday night is tinfoil hat comedy
night at Cobbs in San Francisco
eight o'clock show Live Nation and
punch-drunk Live Nation and all things
comedy presents tinfoil hat comedy with
Eddie Bravo Trez mala off-the-grid and
myself and then the next night June 2nd
I met the sacramental punchline same
show get your tickets it's gonna be
glorious that's amazing let me ask you
something do they uh at Cobbs today
do they sell pizza oh no I'd say they
had a weird thing so they stopped
errantly everybody in San Francisco's
lactose intolerant so they on to pizza
I'm not even a gluten-free pizza nope
how cuz they got gluten-free pizza at
Pizza nice that we're all on Wednesday
if I'm glue if I have if I'm lactose
intolerance because there's gluten in
there
ORS no I'm just saying like it like
sometimes they'll have a gluten-free
that's all you're so that isn't even the
problem sure okay here's some
gluten-free you're like oh that doesn't
really help [ __ ] you
I was just asking if they had a gluten
free or regular pizza or anything you
know but they don't have any pizza and
again
June 9th June 9th June 9th we are at the
Sycamore tavern for UFC 225 Jason Tebow
fight nany Johnny Woodward and Jason's
best friend Mickey
gah we'll be there guess what there's no
cover there's no free parking it's free
parking that's really the best secrets
about that spot that spot is amazing no
it's a great spot you're welcome it's a
good spot you're welcome
I uh let it go I Pat we packed it out
last time so we're gonna get there early
decide where we want to sit and we'll
get all the tables I don't even like but
I'm going I want to do the whole back
corner the problem is we're going to do
some table rearranging yeah you know
what I'm saying
so yeah Oh Sycamore tavern Oh on Sunset
no you know I that's where I am
I watched the Eagles win the Super Bowl
remember that game I do I do i watch the
news once what happen um Patriots lost
yeah yeah the Patriots lost there was a
part in the game where Tom Brady like
was on his butt and he was just kind of
had his head down and he was kind of
looking like oh no I don't think we're
gonna win this one and they didn't yeah
didn't they didn't hold on like we hang
up on Ari seriously qui up on him no I
could still hear him and III hate
hearing in business there we go off so
the sound of slice would he do that
the rubber in her face that he's moving
and shaking I mean he could have done
that in dates out the gates but he
didn't participate yeah he didn't he's
obviously selling something to somebody
and he's working really hard on selling
it yeah he doesn't have to pitch his
dates his dates are sold out I guess
probably yeah all around the world must
be nice
must be nice mine aren't though so
Wednesday come on out to pizza nice the
Long Beach yeah come get some dude get
it you listen to some comedy and you
don't enjoy it up a slice enjoy a slice
Long Beach is one of the most underrated
hood cities out there like its hood but
it's fun it's fun
yeah like downtown Long Beach is great
it doesn't feel hoody but then you get
to the you know the periphery of Long
Beach in like oh yeah man you know when
the chicks there get like prison tats
yeah they all have prison tats all the
chicks you could tell it's one that
looks like they just jabbed a Bic pen
into the side of their neck as they
tried to put it like Lolita but they
spelled wrong yeah when it
- looks like it was made with a hammer
and a nail yeah which is alike the time
hammer nail ballpoint pen ink here we go
tattoo tattoo thank you for all the kind
words about last week's episode sounds
like you guys really enjoy our he's
calling in ah let's see how go see how
it goes this time
yo we appreciate the fact that you're
working a lot but we don't need to hear
your business okay he didn't we heard it
all yeah we heard it all we don't
appreciate what you said about us either
you just muted us and then continued
about your day what is this God shot
they we're looking at right now yeah
what is the worst POV porn I've ever
seen in my life
this is like the the other way around
for chick and that's what it looks like
right that's what that's what it's gonna
look some girl lives there somebody
lives there and is happy to be there oh
that's gonna be what Josh Martin is
gonna look at and when Ari files the
[ __ ] out of him I can see why they don't
have this version of POV porn on youporn
you like - not very it's not very
exciting we gotta face it women get the
raw end of the deal on Saturday before a
point of Geo porn I'm gonna be honest
Jay yeah I've never been put in a great
movie because I suck some chicks [ __ ]
hole you know what I mean so they get
the raw end of the deal but they get all
the all the good uh all the all the good
gifts like I think we get the wrong deal
they get the they have to behold the
glory of our [ __ ] there's something
creepy about your friend sang [ __ ] like
dicks cool but when your friends like
[ __ ] I'm like dude you're creeping
everybody out here yeah now you don't
know this David eerie they literally had
a sexual harassment seminar simply based
on Ari Shaffir they at all things comedy
at all things County and they just
showed his basically said oh is that
serious oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah for sure
was it the candy bars in the but what
was it no it wasn't here that was in
Bobby
okay that well there you go him walking
around an acre with is you moon nuts
coming you know
you might you know it might have been
when all three of us [ __ ] a donut and
had a girl eat it I mean there's a lot
of things there in the pamphlet like
here's some examples of sexual
harassment punch-drunk episode 47
punch-drunk episode 94 exactly it was a
super hero called Pam let and then it
was just all like sexual stuff with like
her like shoving that pamphlet or a
[ __ ] and stuff like that's a superpower
right that is a superpower man pamphlet
alright go make another phone call you
are you're funnier when you were getting
your cable bill squid up squandered away
all right where you gonna be
where you gonna be re gonna be in
Washington DC this weekend nice visited
the old grub - OH - I think you won -
one of those all right why don't you get
the two one two tattooed we'll all get
our area codes on us somewhere go to a
hockey game are you gonna go to a hockey
game understand the cup yeah why you
should do that maybe Game three will be
right when you're there what do you
think those tickets closet what do you
think those tickets cost it's hockey for
400 bucks probably 400 I do in a
heartbeat 4 to 6 well if you're away up
top 400 I mean if you want to go let's
go for hockey that's not a bad seat yeah
oh no yeah all seats are good at yes
yeah for sure
because you are bandwagon fan of
everything so now because the team that
I like the least this is the only one
I'm allowed to root for probably no
you're allowed to roof or anybody you
want you just happen to pick teams that
always one that's the problem that's
crazy it is crazy how lucky I go ha ha
ha I'm good too Yankees and the Cowboys
and the hatred and what Bastien the
warrior they hug the Clippers it was
like the big 3 they were supposed to do
all these dreamy things and nothing had
and the best time possible to take the
reign of LA away from Los Angeles
when the Lakers were bad and missed
about five you were bad they still are
history they could have grabbed all
these young kids who know I'm not a
Laker fan I'm a clipper fan they're
badass what happened
what's it happened what happened the
owner lost is mine yeah he just resigned
doc so we're [ __ ]
yeah we're [ __ ] we're Fox it goes bad
it goes real bad I met the owner before
Ballmer
oh yeah well the year we were supposed
to win it so then it was like now it's
time I still trust Jerry West I still
trust him I still trust him well yeah I
mean it's not like he's been here for
five years either he just got one year
and turn it on exactly yeah so we'll see
what he does he's got to pretty high
picks 12 and 13 we'll see how it goes
I'd like to pair them he's gonna die
trying it now are you like what's your
what's your like a creative process do
you go hey what do what do they care
about and how can I just [ __ ] on it and
set it on fires out the perfect day I
can just not ruin any day know what that
is yeah really it's gotta be a great
point of view but also it's a lot of
realistic truth in there as well you
know yeah there you go
Wow learn from the man full circle who
was that it always goes back to Hitler I
was thinking the other day speaking of
Hitler speaking of him like that you
know you really got it because I was
reading a thing about this new Tarantino
movie about Manson yeah and yeah yeah I
thought he retired by the way did you
know he died but they get a start we got
to really be more sensitive to failed
artists like if they would have just let
Hitler in art school the whole world
would be different yeah if if the Beach
Boys would have just helped Manson get
his music career going like he was
begging him to a lot of people probably
wouldn't have died by the way his album
looks good I don't know if you guys have
heard his music it's it's our intro on
the show it's good yeah we play every
episode we just play out Manson's whole
album so now it's like a lot of people
you know like
like an aerco Ligny type or something
like that let's get this guy a comedy
album yeah why do you think I'm nice to
everybody that me so I'm like they could
come and shoot everybody alright alright
and then get all the in sells late I
mean next that's true everyone that's
gonna [ __ ] and cry gets a everyone gets
a trophy yes what it is okay because one
truck antler deal with it I got cut from
the basketball team I didn't go [ __ ]
kill a whole race of people because of I
mean luckily Jordan got his [ __ ]
together because when he got cut in high
school he could have gone in a [ __ ]
killing epic killing spree what do you
think Jordan didn't make so accurately
shots what do you think what do you
think Jordan would do if he did make the
NBA what do you think like with that
kind of attitude and like just I just
[ __ ] personality where would he go yeah
you know I think Tommy star I think
honestly his dad would still be alive
possibly yeah that's true
coming out the gates hot what are your
sacred cows let me say that's that but
that's that butterfly effect yeah well
dude I mean like how much money do you
have to make to be like no I'm not gonna
pay you and then they're like we're
gonna kill your dad you're like go [ __ ]
yourself yeah he has so much money
eventually [ __ ] crazy he get that he
when he went to baseball was it because
he was gambling on NBA games is that
what it was
yeah but they don't but it's not like
outright it's like it's a secret because
that would destroy the family at that
point games he was gambling he was
gambling on NBA yeah on NBA games yeah
not just gambling on other things that
guy would gamble on everything yeah Wow
here's a D Jen you know and he would
just like so you'd see it in his press
conference he literally says if David
Stern allows me back into the league
I'll come back really yeah yeah he's a
[ __ ] total like yeah he's a degenerate
he's [ __ ] everybody like Jordan could
not survive
I'm in today if he was around today
social media and all that yeah oh yeah
dude look at Tristan Thompson I mean he
can't [ __ ] look at a strippers
butthole without [ __ ] somebody
putting it on TMZ you're the rumor that
Jordan used to [ __ ] right no no no but
the rumor is that Pippen is hung like a
horse like it is a giant root a giant
root when Jordan was [ __ ] me bridge
around like rabbit but not his reach
because it's credibly long wingspan he
was able to use the only one able like
in the reach-around
I like that I like that oh cool man Jeff
do you hear the rumor that will Perdue
and Rory Sparrow we're the same person
seven foot two and white ones like five
eight and black so are you what you've
been up to I went to the woods this
weekend like everybody's camping all the
Sun and Memorial every weekend I guess
how was it who to go with who'd you go
with you near lady yeah just you two of
you no yeah no I was thinking about
killing her the whole time do you think
my killer fantasize about killing her
significant other it's just part of the
thing no yeah we all fantasize about
killing your girlfriend yeah yeah now
you know she looks like but I [ __ ]
fantasize about they keep killing women
till I find her I'm gonna need your
podcast in about a month I can't stop
killing women looking for our ease girl
alright so is this a steady thing right
now yeah it's pretty good we went out to
the cabin [ __ ] nice bro no technology
campfires [ __ ] walks and would you
guys talk about you get romantic did you
hold hands you [ __ ] [ __ ] not once I
do not not once did she try I take that
back then yeah that's fine I was like
get the [ __ ] off me I'm not holding your
hand thinking about murdering you let me
focus well how'd you guys how'd you like
the fire
describe your friar how's your fire
building techniques
he had his assistant to it for him
[Laughter]
and I tie it around my [ __ ] barks come
with the rock over flint makes sense
there you go really dry penguin like I
usually just rub my dick like this
against it against them can we stop
saying [ __ ] on the show but just found
thanks I don't think it's gonna happen
it's making Aaron uncomfortable right
and how's your way
my wife's great huh thank you my mic
wasn't working a second ago I had I had
a joke
all right let's hear it let's pretend
like you came out right now you need it
back yeah we'll set it back up if it's
[ __ ] again dude so rumor is a Scottie
Pippen like on like a horse like he's
got giant like a giant room like a big
[ __ ]
you mean like only the tip in Pippin oh
wow I'm glad you're my keeping with the
tip and turn your mic off okay earmarked
out that started out as mariachi and
then just haunts my nightmares right
what else I would think I would think
Ari would go camping with his girlfriend
and his assistant yeah and it's just
like you make you sit and sleep outside
I need you to build me a fire than I
need you to get the [ __ ] out hey could
you go to Starbucks for us and uh get us
some iced coffee this place sucks
I need you to go check Mike I need you
to leave go to Wi-Fi and check my emails
and come back my coffee guy are you a
coffee guy you're out there like making
coffee and now you don't drink coffee
there you go now did you do guys room
you do just smoke weed yes smoke weed
all day [ __ ] shrooms
it's a Molly jeez oh you went hard in
the paint buddy no heroin shot up heroin
heroin we ate some children
that would be a place to eat children
though I hope you hear this things up
there yeah I'm noticing a pattern here
which is you want to take somebody to
this cabin and murder them guys honestly
think about the people you like if you
could get away with it I mean 100 cent
get away with it no one would ever know
and you can talk about it again mmm
who would you murder that's a great
question yes for all of you I think a
hiking accident would be the easiest way
like if you go out to Yosemite and you
go out there on Half Dome people die out
there all the time it's like oh he
slipped off the ladder man [ __ ] Wow
who'd you kill
long list I just don't I probably would
only not kill Aaron salmon ari everybody
else has got a [ __ ] target on their
back starting with my cut mom Ari who'd
you kill apparently his girlfriend and
children
I think randoms for a while I think I
would get like The Hunger down and then
start kind of like when I started
masturbating I didn't want to do it with
anybody in my class you know like have
that in mind oh oh I'm so you so you
jerk off for the first time and then
you're like okay this is obviously
something very important I got a game
plan this [ __ ] first game plan is don't
jerk off to anybody in your class yeah
not real people that I know that I
create but you are a creep so nobody
ventually he got it he got into it you
know at one point he's like no I'm not a
creep I'm just I'm just right killing
random children yeah yeah I'm not a
creep would you would you like would you
wear their skin as a costume or anything
like really crazy like [ __ ] their dead
bodies or you just like kill and just
for the killing and then I mean
seriously yeah what would be your trophy
you know
[Laughter]
and then I will get bored and I would do
ya start to up it and I would alright
why do you have 40 baby shoes in your
closet don't worry about it but how do
you up it how do you up it just by like
some wearing their teeth on as a
necklace or that's good well wearing
skin yeah wearing golden no shirt
wearing this but I'm not get this chance
again like let me try wearing it by the
way on YouTube you can watch a guy
butcher a whole pig and then he takes
the head and he cuts the skin of the
head and he lays it out like a mask on
the butcher's table and and the first
thought is like yeah he he's worn that
for sure yeah he puts it on and then he
like runs out to his neighbor's he
knocks on the neighbor's door yeah and
then it starts to get fun you know and
II realize this is a [ __ ] freaky
looking mask you know yeah there's some
creepers out there pig's face it's just
like amazing if you watch it on YouTube
my guy butchers a whole pig I'd wear a
pig mask I'm gonna yeah do that I could
definitely see you going to one of those
weird Eyes Wide Shut party 100% get your
weird funky in there re are you one of
those Eyes Wide Shut parties like we're
all the successful people go and they
[ __ ] poor people have you have you been
in any of those yet is that an option
how do you get to be one of the poor
people to get [ __ ] by rich people I be
really hot you gotta be really really
high one ball one and desperate ball -
yeah right - yeah right - oh yeah that
is the whole thing I cry a lot yeah I
just you know just whisper dead-eyed
dead-eyed quiet [ __ ] yeah yeah I cry a
lot when I [ __ ] I know you do that's why
I've heard when I'm getting [ __ ] Wow
buy life
no buy dudes oh yeah I get that but
they're with their big [ __ ] right all
right we're just saying [ __ ] too much um
[ __ ] it's too much embrace it it's to
embrace the [ __ ] all right what's hot
in the New York City comedy scene what's
hot was he keeps talking about well
Roseanne Barr
senator tweet today and then she was her
show's canceled I'm talking about that
we were in live we were talking that
before yeah yeah yeah Oh her amazing
show on television it's insane what is
it the most the top rated show yeah and
she put out that this one woman who were
to Obama administration look like
somebody from the plan of the apes and
it's just like you dude you just costs
so many people money unbelievable I mean
how do you kill money what money
someone's gonna go in that time slot
that's true maybe they should do Rosen's
Dead episode like like John Goodman goes
out to the log cabin right can he kills
her yeah [ __ ] carves her face puts it
on the table and wears it why not
because she makes some how about it's
just super meta like she makes a tweet
on the show and then and then he gets
fired they all get fired from their jobs
and then he just goes ham and he just
cuts her face off
yeah crazy that she who I mean I get
that it that's corporate [ __ ] involved
can say something like that and get her
show cancelled Trump says [ __ ] like that
every day he's not getting cancelled
he's not tweeting like oh this looks
like an ape well kind of like what he
said that they're animals hold on dude
listen to me you have to give on the
context of what he's talking about ms-13
do is how he's talking about image there
Pacifica Lee yeah I don't know to be
honest with you of course they know but
okay obviously ms-13 I know but also but
also you have to be careful like the
context where you use things as well no
because people are gonna hear they
literally are going like defending ms-13
and they're like they're born to a world
of [ __ ] but those dudes when you get a
[ __ ] face tattoo of a 13 on your face
it's it's over stick a fork all right
we'll forget that that is that Mexicans
aren't bringing their best you know
before he said you know he says a lot of
[ __ ] up weird [ __ ] you know I mean
I'm not the fat mother I don't give a
[ __ ] man I'm not like on the PC brigade
or anything like that he's just talking
[ __ ] he's a desperate man you know who
cares I don't care what he says I don't
even really pay attention I mean she's
an antiquated comic that made and I
don't think she should an appropriate
joke I don't think she should be canned
either I mean I don't think like we know
she's a [ __ ] batshit crazy person
yeah I just let her make a [ __ ] baby
just wanted out and she just gave him
the perfect way to do it he played that
perfectly' didn't she she got out just
at the right time she was already out
right
she got out like I'm off I'm God he's
bounced so weird
yeah they got picked up first season two
and then she announced that she's not
gonna be sure on her season two it was
you know tour dates and all that sort of
stuff and then a month later bye Felicia
bye Felicia
well guys you know not you know what's
coming up it's off Father's Day and
that's right so we're working again with
our good friends at Omaha Steaks that's
right Father's Day is just around the
corner are you trying to find the
perfect gift for your father for
Father's Day
do your does your dad love the grill but
hate the hassle of poor quality of the
grocery store well what better way to
kick off grilling season then by gifting
Omaha Steaks Father's Day package to
your dad all right feel free I mean it's
it's crazy dude it's convenient Omaha
Steaks
delivers hand trimmed flash fruit frozen
and vacuum sealed meats directly to your
door in Omaha steak coolers there's pork
there's poultry there's veal there's let
lamb and I since each two bowls all the
highest-quality cuts with a
one-of-a-kind flavor all beef is USDA
inspected for quality and aged for 21
days to unlock the full flavor and
tremendous tenderness of the cuts and
don't worry are they of course as well
yeah when they do ads with us today is
any language of the contract that you
have to be able to read English no no
it's not even Oh apparently I'm the
adult and I have to do all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] right now Omaha Steaks
is giving a little
never done an ad read why have I never
done one for Omaha Steaks for anybody
I'll read one I have a great commercial
voice Omaha Steaks is giving a limited
time offer to our listeners for Father's
Day at 78 percent off this is a really
amazing deal
it's 78 percent off go to Omaha Steaks
comm type punch-drunk in the search bar
and you can get the Omaha Steaks
Father's Day package which includes to
tender filet mignons to beefy sirloins
for chicken-fried steaks to boneless
chops pork chops all beef but I mean the
list goes on and on it's amazing dude
it's amazing all the stuff again again
this is a limited time package offer for
only $49.99 when you get your 50 bucks
you get like two hundred and fifty
dollars really made all this [ __ ] is
incredible
712 ounces of all beef meatballs one
pound of steak house fries it's all free
it's all zero I'll throw it in the
freezer flour milk help
they got I'll come probably they have
everything else again go to Omaha Steaks
comm type punch trunk of the search bar
and add Father's Day package to your car
don't wait they offer ends soon go to
Omaha Steaks calm type punch trunk in
the search bar and grab your deal for
your dad right now if you do if you
Jewish they have kosher meats and you
don't even have to do if your dad maybe
you have a lesbian moms and because
because you're the other one that can
afford it re because what happens is
they hit me up for an address right so I
hit you up for an address and I never
hear back from you well dude I want to
hear a fourth and fifth time okay I'm
not [ __ ] keeping re re
they got 78% off it's a deal he's 50
bucks it's the money to go in there use
it every time they send it you're like
oh I'm in Thailand for a month [ __ ]
you don't get the goddamn meat you
should coordinate with them all right
when you right away all right coordinate
with your sponsors all right hey don't
send the meats in in July I'm gonna be
over in Thailand
alright oq up here's what you do go to
Omaha Steaks calm music oh
punch-drunk and that saves you 78% of
yeah that's better than 75% it is not
$50 and guess what you do put your
address in there and they'll send it to
you yeah you are I want things for free
how much are you gonna spend on Stanley
Cup tickets how much would you spend you
spend a lot to go to the the college
football national champ okay I mean this
[ __ ] costs money
probably 500 he spent 500 yeah you would
be able to is it to they don't do two
three two there do they
I know I think they do too yeah I think
so you'll be four games three and four
will be when you're at home another one
is it do to one-on-one I think it's two
to one one one yeah yeah yeah yeah hey
turn your flip phone off Jesus gotta go
play snake what are you selling ice
cream in the neighborhood what is that
did the snake meeting his father going
[ __ ] Dean bro
oh yeah ah yeah I never stop cow until
you pick up it's important all right so
let's get into this um let's get in to
the NBA playoffs
they've been very interesting so far
it's not some [ __ ] cp3 going down the
Rockets are in the finals
I agree mult I agree I took her over if
they didn't have 27 shots in a row to
the Warriors in game 7 they missed 27
shots in a row which is an NBA record in
the playoffs 2027 three points yeah 20
centers in a row I read it I don't know
how they get the staff but someone said
it was like one there's like a 1 in
750,000 of a chance you know one in our
home how about this astronaut let's say
you're the coach
stop shooting threes yeah we're
obviously off tonight on hit on these
threes and their cook they're clearly
coming back that was the same thing that
wasn't what pissed me all about the
Sixers cuz when they went cold on the
threes they never just like just jam it
into em bead and just try to get to you
know what I mean yes change your
strategy play Nene at all and it's like
that guy can bang down low yeah I have
no answer for the threes aren't falling
bang down low dog and then maybe dish it
back out and hit it's like we're gonna
shoot our way out of this I mean
apparently you're not gonna dude Eric
Gordon Eric Gordon James Harden and
Trevor Ariza I mean they had a John
Starks type game dude yeah I mean me I
mean at home that's several reasons of
it playing good Ari if you took twenty
seven three-pointers in a row
you'd make at least one yes it's not in
a game I get it but we're also not
professionals I think any one of us 27
in a row well he would get okay he would
get tired for less no he would get nine
in who Sam sepiol oh here's the craziest
thing re I could I don't cuz I feel bad
enough that's coming I don't want I'm
still 47 percent from the 58 9 out of 20
yeah that's so 40 faster whatever here's
a good point shooter yeah Thank You Ari
god I'd like to sorry even though he
kills kids in the cabin he's a good dude
hey
with that you'll get tired on shop 21 to
27 wouldn't probably Houston clearly did
probably never athletes they got tired
at shot 1 yeah obviously
oh here's the crazy thing Houston
doesn't have another point guard on
their roster they're all shooting guards
who with handles how do you have CP 3 on
your team and not have a backup point
guard yeah harder point guard to play
but he's not a point guard he's a
shooting guard with good handles he's
not a point guard and that's the problem
and he had all those turnovers in the
last two games and that's what [ __ ]
him
I mean besides missing shot obviously
but this Finals bores me
oh wow the Warriors you just get
warriors just gonna blow mout it's gonna
be travel by five five games city six
hiccup hey curry and just make him get
injured they have to get an injury to
have any chance right without an injury
you see those shots Golden State was
hitting in that second half oh they go
they go ham in the third three sneak
behind the line with the hand in your
face and I catch and shoot and it's just
like bang bang they would take shots and
I'd be like oh that's a stupid job yes I
went in you know what Golden State was
versus Houston that it was it was
private school versus public school yeah
okay and I'll tell you why because
you're right cuz curry and um play time
you bought grew up in NBA gyms with NBA
coaches teaching them how to shoot yeah
the other guys were just [ __ ] learning
in the streets you know teaching
themselves yeah
you know try not to hit the [ __ ] the
shoes that are on the [ __ ] telephone
wire you know get into a milk crate yeah
yeah so it's just like these guys are
calibrated caliber no backboard you know
wires is do you know Jeff Jeff Jeff oh
sure why you mean where it comes from
the telephone the shoes over a telephone
wire I've heard a lot of different
theories what's your theory Ari oh well
I just heard that they sell drugs in
this block that's one theory
cuz who would it throw them up there
well you know it did that's good to know
what to let people know they can buy
drugs if you like it
come you actually look that up on
Wikipedia there's like four different in
the same Wikipedia thing there's four
different theories of what it is and
that was one of them the other one is an
idiot lost his shoes there are like
three different ones one of them's got a
boy on that block now based on the color
of the shoe is what drugs they sell
right I don't really if it's white it's
crack if it's green it's it's weed if
it's yellow its meth what else we got
children grow gray it's heroin yes thank
you for selling the show to do that that
was great
I've had some really great moments maybe
you and Aaron should get together and
just [ __ ] punch some [ __ ] Edward is
lucky he didn't get Aaron's joke music
after that yeah I don't I'm actually
gonna be more excited about this
if the Stanley Cup continues after how
Game one was oh it will yeah we way more
exciting than a finals yeah hockey at
first I mean that was what six - what
was the final six four I mean that and
if that's gonna if that if that's a tell
of how this finals is gonna go in hockey
I'm Way more into the NHL than the NBA
right now the NBA has to be like [ __ ]
this ain't good
the same two teams for four years in a
row and the problem is it's not
competitive yes not it's not even like
you don't know who's gonna win is their
champion surprised yeah dude I mean like
curry got hurt during his way off he
didn't play some games that's true dude
without curry this is Oklahoma City
the Warriors our Oklahoma City yeah with
curry that's a special team yeah he's a
next-level baller dude
okay he's and dude let's say they win
three out of the last four championships
that's a dynasty definitely that's an
all-time great you know I mean like who
were the Lakers teams playing when they
were head Shaq and Kobe and they were on
that like vicious run was it always the
same teams or will they go through
Sacramento you remember
how the Santa Maria oh you mean the UH
when uh Pilate hits the ball out to
Robert Horry just think about oh yeah
yeah yeah the Robert Horry good with
those Kings be in today's NBA oh yeah in
the east imagine that no but in even
west they would kill it because just so
everybody could shoot threes on that
team major story ah kovitch wasn't it
yeah he was young
Terkel ooh ah you know Mike baby Chris
Webber could shoot threes I mean they
were all great they would kill it I
loved Chris Webber I do too he's gonna
be in the Hall of Fame the question is
is Carmelo Anthony a Hall of Famer
I don't think so I don't think so
yeah yeah exactly he's not like that's
it he has 10 he's a 10 time all-star
great players Hall of Fame players make
the whole team good look at like LeBron
does he's always ya know no one when
he's traded away no one's ever like oh
man bummer you know what I mean like if
the situation were a traded Iverson the
whole the city would have burned yeah
yeah I mean he was great I didn't love
yeah it's like so much that's the
definition of like for me like a Hall of
Famer and I mean he's just he's an
individual player who just makes
everyone around him better and it's like
he makes the team better carries the
team when he has to it's like I didn't
see Carmelo Anthony as that type of
player he's a great player but it's like
if Joe Dumars hadn't been an idiot and
drafted Carmelo Anthony with the second
pick and he goes to Detroit
instead of Darko Miletich where they are
he had a bunch of big guys they need him
right and they needed a three yeah
imagine how his career is totally
different yeah he's going to veterans
who are gonna put him in his place
tell him shut the [ __ ] I mean I know one
thing Jordans dad wouldn't have been
dead if they did that that's a great
point to maybe not it's about Jordans
dad oh my god you know finally we all
agree on something
the guy was a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
to much much car too much car how many
times you said that what's that why re
your son's death [ __ ] ya cheap rich
people
I don't either re re explain yourself
I think Artie could be really rich if
you want to I think he's good
would you think would you be cheap if
you were if you were Yeah right it just
doesn't go away it's just in you right
well would you be cheap if you were a
billionaire or a moaner not cheap yeah
yeah yeah I mean I'd be losing all my
money to [ __ ] baby mama drama
just cuz I'd be knocking up everybody
did you watch did you watch any of the
Stanley Cup game I will bow though
all righty do you see any of it yeah I
mean did you see the intro which if this
is what the Raiders are gonna do I'm so
in you don't like it no I didn't see it
oh it was the coolest thing I've ever
seen interest for the Knights are
amazing this is one they outdid
themselves well dude it's it's it's
vacant do they call that they know how
to like put on a show dude this one was
it was as good at the game so it's crazy
they brought carrot top out on the
center ice and then he and then then
they brought the knight out and they had
this like I don't know how they did it
with like special effects the knight
just took care of heads to eat took care
of tops head right off just cut his head
off
in redolent that was in real life oh it
wasn't even special and the fans went
crazy yeah last night and then the one
so the one last night like that this guy
comes flying out of the sky with the
night who's skating around and doing
this whole thing they have this whole
sword fight and then he and it shit's
going on all around the arena and encho
and he stabs the ice with his sword and
with all the special effects on the ice
it looks like all the ice cracked around
the dude and he fell in and [ __ ] is
incredible it was so rad yeah it's nuts
I saw the one where they had the night
he's like standing on the on the ice and
then they have this giant plane like
projected on it looks like an airplane
and it's like this loud noise and it did
it like shoots towards the night and he
like holds a sword out and the plane
just like splits in half and crashes and
burns and 9/11
then there's a tower a couple yeah I'm
saying it 9/11 was the inside pretty
much yeah the [ __ ] Golden Knights I
love it
I'm so excited for Vegas man I'm really
excited for Vegas I mean what a cool
story that they just got a hockey team
and go to the Stanley Cup Finals like
it's unbelievable right away cool they
definitely did the expansion draft
differently than some of the leases on
it well people know uh people don't
remember that the Panthers and the Jags
went pretty deep into the playoffs very
early NFC AFC Finals yeah when they
early a game away from the Super Bowl in
their inaugural season yeah and their
way oh man we can't do this again you
know so we all know that sports are
fixed oh whatever
yeah for sure dude for of course Vegas
is gonna make it I mean come on guys get
on board with all the money come out
here to Vegas move to Vegas gambled bet
game yeah uh watching party watch
they're gonna watch they're gonna win it
Vegas way better than I do but that a
big watching party I guess outside of
the arena is well yeah there had to be
50,000 people outside there dude and
when they showed when there was a goal I
mean it was insane the first goal and
they showed all the people outside the
team it's like the World Cup I they
finally got approached well you know
it's so funny it's like all these Vegas
people now are getting [ __ ] from people
they're like [ __ ] been why I gave you
like what do you mean been Romagna huh I
can't ban whack everybody's a bandwagon
it's a brand new team
yeah it's so stupid no but you didn't
start liking them so till the 10th game
yeah you're wack how exactly
oh is there for the draft I saw a
preseason game pitch yeah
Vegas I mean everybody goes there every
day I'm I'm Instagram you just see porn
stars and strippers I'll go in the
[ __ ] night's game yes when the
Raiders are here it's gonna be I'm
saying I hope you have the same
pageantry I hope the NFL allows them to
have that same pageanty you dude Vegas
is gonna go nuts everyone thinks it's
gonna be away games all the time for the
Raiders
cuz everyone's gonna fly it I don't
think so Raiders have a pretty strong
they base you know it's gonna be
great they're gonna be great but anyways
let's go back to the playoffs
uh here's the thing about LeBron and
this all I must say [ __ ]
congratulations he's a great player I
love watching him play great dude he's
great he did anybody to get there but
that's not his fault oh he didn't take
on the top four players in the East he
didn't play any of them besides himself
oh you take him out think I read listen
as well and then your two guys on your
jimin's yeah didn't play any not a fault
not his fault
not his fault motive the wealth right
like I'm telling you dude pelicans
versus the Cavs is way more and they're
the 7c to me was yeah is way more
competitive than anybody thinks yeah
yeah but I mean he did his part I mean
he did his part against the well coach
team the Celtics or have one of the best
coaches and I think he's the best coach
in the NBA
they're a great they're a great
defensive team and and LeBron just did
his thing you know what I mean they they
shut down veterans and Joel embiid like
I knew when the bosses lost it is this
one it was like towards you in the
fourth quarter exactly down maybe ten or
something and they just know they
weren't even down ten they were down six
or something yeah they just start
chucking threes at the Reebok yeah and
then so just check I'm like why is he
called timeout right there yeah this I
don't know why I think you'd know is
there a new rule in the NBA you can't
bring three timeouts to the final two
minutes is that like a new rule really
III don't think that I know I heard them
saying that you can't carry three
timeouts to the to the end of the before
I'm like what maybe because they don't
want to just keep going but dude why
don't you call a timeout right there and
reset or at least just do what what do
they do in the NFL they just give a
30-second timeout right just give him
like a quick timeout
well I mean like a two-minute warning no
and I think in football they give them
like longer timeout and then they give
them like a because sometimes like
that's a 30-second timeout so they only
get 30 seconds oh yeah so just get a
shorter time out yeah just be if they
don't want the game to go on but it's
the playoffs I mean come on
playoffs it's the boss I mean let them
let him have timeouts yeah thanks I mean
here's the thing George Hill is great
he's not Kyrie he's a different kind of
guy but he's a better defensive player
than Kyrie off Kyrie if if green can
actually become the player that
everybody thought Green was gonna be
when he came to Lee cuz he looks like he
can ball what's his name green on the
Cavs I can't remember his first name but
he looks like he can ball he look second
to me and there's just something off he
never can rise to the expectations and
then Kevin Love who knows what happens
what love I mean they're actually better
when he's not on the floor which is
[ __ ] sucks insane yeah LeBron he's
just never been that good number two guy
who's only a good number one guy know
he's really good on a team where there's
no pressure
well examples don't moments they're
there you just ain't good when the trip
is not good yeah he's not that good when
the Timberwolves suck nobody in February
no one's coming into Minnesota
geared up they're just like let's just
get through this [ __ ] game so you
could put up big numbers I call it the
Elton Brand effect yeah I mean in the
NBA it's like everybody's amazing
they're professional athletes but Slyke
when you get to the playoffs that's like
when you get to the Comedy Store you
don't I mean like oh oh you're a great
comedian you're a great comedian but
then you go to the bar and you're with
Diaz and Grogan and and just watch
people just not rise up you know what I
mean it's just another level in the
playoffs and like man LeBron does it
it's amazing he he knows where he's at
he he didn't even sit on the bench for a
[ __ ] minute did those block shots
where he's coming from behind we're like
I say I'm in the playoffs I don't even
know what drug he is on right to be this
long in the NBA and still playing not
possible he's on he's on I mean they all
are look how jacked even if it's legal
they're on something because there's
always like the doc no there's got some
[ __ ] Nikes guys like yeah Nike one in
this room they're like try this [ __ ]
they can't detect it and it's basically
made of [ __ ] like orphaned children
and you just [ __ ] ever said 100% look
at everybody around him like that whole
class he came in with throw out this
integrator did you see that documentary
Icarus by the way the doping documentary
it's amazing it's I don't care I know I
don't know what they're do it's like
there's no way you can it's it's you
can't why not
they're always wants that supplements
okay but HGH is not I have no idea is
better yeah I guess but I don't know I
just don't get it cuz you you're never
gonna stop these guys there's so much
money involved it's in the interest of
sports for the people to be the best
that they can possibly be
so they pretend like they care but they
don't give a [ __ ]
give me a break [ __ ] you don't think
they want someone [ __ ] dunking from
half-court and they don't give a [ __ ]
about the person I don't either dude no
I mean either baseball just tried to
make it a big deal and all the other
sports are like yeah whatever and they
move on by the way baseball needs it the
most that's the most boring [ __ ] sport
I'll leave the line smacking [ __ ]
homers yeah but it's like boring if
pitchers aren't unhittable
and if batters aren't smacking homers so
it's like if everyone's just a normal
human human it's boring re are and Aaron
this is another question for you
try not to [ __ ] this one up um are that
homeruns up or down I felt I heard that
they're down 30% they're up there up
there up throw up again from last year
well this - no middle of her last year
but last year liked it was insane number
than I thought I heard them say like
homeruns are down 30% it's like what
what changed well one thing that changed
is the weather I mean we had that crazy
winter storm I mean baseball games are
snowed out the balls are colder the bats
are colder everyone's physically cold I
mean there was snowing during baseball
games so the first time that I can
recall in a very long time yeah a lot of
the new parks that they're building have
like homeruns you know they're built for
homeruns I know the Phillies stadium is
kind of built for homerun they should be
yeah yeah I agree they should be they
should force they should for stealing
you'd have to lease steal a couple times
in the game like that just go I said
this before you should be allowed to hit
one batter should be allowed to hit one
battery game in the face and get rid of
lifts get rid of these shifts they're
stupid it looks done I like them that's
so ridiculous you're like it's weird
right this lightly
I'm to a major league baseball player
yeah I was thinking that
as the Phillies I was at the Dodgers
game in the Phillies pitcher had a
no-hitter through five or six and Chase
Utley's up and they had this huge shift
on and I'm like dude all he's got to do
is just stick the bat out you know
that's what they do just hit it there
and you know Chase Utley such a baseball
guy he I would feel like that he'd be
like against it he'd be like nope I got
a legitimately try to get a hit because
this guy's got a no-hitter I don't want
to like [ __ ] him I respect his no-hitter
I'd be like [ __ ] that I'm gonna just tap
or do what he do he struck out yeah but
this thing we we broke it with a double
when like the sixth I think we'd such so
maddening dude it Dodgers I saw this
thing there was I think twenty years ago
yesterday that Barry Bonds Barry Bonds
was walked intentionally with the bases
loaded Barry Bonds yeah they're like
[ __ ] it we're up three let's give them a
run and we don't want this guy getting a
grand slam and winning intentional IBB
like that I'd be BR now how can we solve
that I think they should have strategy I
think that's a good strategy it's never
happened for anything I've been a walk
it's the same [ __ ] anything else I mean
if they win that game I'm like hey man
that's a good strategy I think I think
all pitchers should be fat and out of
shape and get tired real quick so
there's more runs I like fat pitchers I
tell you how do you make baseball more
interesting I've said this before on the
show landlines no no animals you just
release wild animals into the field and
you just see the survives cliff Robinson
get him involved somehow spiked balls
Cliff Robertson from the Trailblazers
that's the one
ok ok ok talk me through this talk me
through this yeah pretty much made the
headband cool whether you liked it or
not that's true that's a good point huh
eating of a [ __ ] played smooth off the
bench didn't care where he got put just
a good player
the ball
guy who's bald right yeah yeah yeah he
bald okay yeah Jordan may be involved
cool yeah do you know they say those men
fitness magazines sell more magazines
when the bald guys on it than a guy with
hair isn't that weird
yeah well then why am I not on there
yeah shave your head dude
seriously no I think that's not what I
mean but yeah um what else did you see
that Champions League goal yeah no it
wasn't that quality Sadie I love good
soccer
oh well Cup are you guys excited or yeah
I am did we make it now we didn't make
it
we didn't I don't know what happened to
our team we had yalter amazing coach
Russian team on us going there yeah
that's possible man I'm telling you what
I'm bringing and finding the World Cup
and I'm going to Russia for the World
Cup I'm bringing my own food I'm going
to [ __ ] Omaha Steaks calm putting in
the code punch-drunk
everything's freeze-dried I wouldn't
trust anything in Russia
why because they've cheated at
everything they've ever done they
cheated in the Olympic stage they moved
from the Olympics and it couldn't be
called Russia they had to be called the
team from like if you win a medal it
doesn't count gosh Icarus that's what
it's about it's about the Russians
cheating in the Olympics just getting
stone called cold [ __ ] nailed and you
know what here's a birthday cake for you
next thing you know you got diarrhea and
you can't [ __ ] know you're LeBron
James crazy of course they're gonna go
the other way they're gonna get
everybody sick and just roll right
through the [ __ ] World Cup you had
that you had to dope it was state it was
like mandatory if you're on the team you
had to dope right yeah like getting an
ice block everyone has to get a nice
today like yeah you have to line up for
your pills in your shop you had to dope
which meant they had to catch a certain
amount of people doping because they
can't have a 100 percent dope free team
or would look shady so imagine like you
just come into the office one day and
they're like oh yeah you you tested
positive for for uh you know steroids
you're not gonna be in the Olympics how
[ __ ] up is that so obviously it's like
you're an athlete you live in Russia at
your dream to bobsled no and you're
probably even if you're not good
but you're just like it's your dream
you're gonna go to the [ __ ] Olympics
you're gonna bobsled yeah and suddenly
they're like nah what a weird sport to
be like probably yeah obviously not he
said it was it was mandatory everybody
know but he's saying like obviously if
the person is good enough to like win a
medal they're not going all right right
still it's still their dream to go well
you don't want be last guy on the team
because that's the dude who's getting
busted yeah you're like no it's illegal
yeah and that's crazy they like they
used that whole like nationally know
that nationalistic pride of winning all
the medals it was like the most medals
in the Olympics and then they just
attacked the Ukraine you know what I
mean they just like yeah they're there
on some [ __ ] yeah did I if I was in the
World Cup I'd yeah I'll be freeze-dried
shipping my own food I don't not even
drinking their water I'm not trusting
[ __ ] but honestly the US team [ __ ] up
they fired that coat the coach the
German guy I'm a guy yeah and and they
didn't like what he was doing even
though he was crushing in the last World
Cup that they were in he got to the
[ __ ] round of 16 and played Belgium
one of the best teams in the [ __ ]
world and only lost like I think two to
one I think they lost two to one or one
nothing it's like that that's a prideful
soccer's like rx6
yeah I mean like this every other
country we go on this is their main
sport but it's not like course not you
know what it's not as big as golf well I
mean they sell out those are like those
arenas for a major league soccer cell
are they really yeah and how about that
guy on Zoltan who came here and just was
like I was at I I wanna go see a game we
should all go he's amazing yeah the
Swedish guy I was that kimmel yeah it
took my mom when my mom was in town when
we got to go see came home and backstage
and he was the guest house the show
[ __ ] super cool guy really funny
really even hockey ibrahimovic or
whatever his name's not even he's
Swedish I like that guy man does he like
to [ __ ]
he probably does he likes to [ __ ] car
and I loves the [ __ ] trying to find this
golf I'm gonna show Sam this goal ah
yeah I love World Cup cuz it's like you
get to see like why people love soccer
when I feel like precision it might be
like 6:00 in the morning because it's in
Russia see the problem Major League
Soccer in the United States is it's
gonna be what happened to the to the
WNBA and just hear me out
the reason the WNBA it was it's it's the
inferior product to the NBA that's a big
problem but they have to do their league
in the summer because the number one
women's basketball league in the world
that pays well is in Russia during the
winter so all the players go play there
because they make good money over there
and then they come here and they play
you know and it's their offices you're
talking about are you talking about the
American national team how about major
league side I'm talking about what
woman's voice ball why woman's man why
are soccer league will not be okay you
never pay what they look at Brazil where
some of the best players in the world
come from there they're um they're
soccer league is weak it's super weak
Brazil yeah their league not their
national because they're all guys they
all go to Europe and in England where
the money is a lot of money I mean you
see how much they pay just to trade for
a player oh yeah it's it's it's it's
insane its millions of years now do the
do do the players gonna need that money
or is that just owned well I mean they
get a new contract and they get like I
mean yeah they kind of get that money
through the contract that they get but I
think the team gets the money between
the teams but who knows I mean [ __ ]
they're getting like sixty million
dollars they get paid I love that like
you so much rock you get sent down to
lower league oh yeah if a team sucks
incentive we have no reason it's also
great if your team's not that great in
the top league but then they're like the
best team in the second-leg then you're
like as a fan base you're hyped up again
you get something to believe in you know
if the browns if the Browns to go down
yeah the Browns owner the Oakland
Athletics owner like get rid of all
those guys that's the problem with these
sport
Oh ders it's the owners for you don't
get rid of bad owners yeah bad hey I'm
in the long run they can't get rid of
bad owners yeah oh dude I'm excited for
the World Cup even though the US isn't
it innit I'm still excited they [ __ ]
up they had that guy Jurgen Klinsmann
that was the thing they like they like I
don't know who or where or what but see
this guy the German guy Jurgen Klinsmann
who also took Germany deep in the World
Cups as well he he wanted to recruit
American players that were born in
Europe that had like an American dad but
had an American passport right so
there's a German player he's born in
Germany cuz his dad I don't know
whatever and then a lot of people were
like they're not real Americans you know
we gotta we gotta get our players from
inside our you know our college ranks
and it's like yeah do that as well but
the best players are born in Europe
right and in England where they grow up
with the game they don't play basketball
in high school you know what I mean
and um yeah so he had a great team he
liked obviously great like no strategy
you know coach the German national team
that's like the best one of the top five
teams in the world every year and I
don't know what happened I'm not that in
the we lost to a couple teams we
shouldn't lost to he's not the coach
anymore Yeah right right the new coach
no no he went deep in the World Cup and
then he was done no new coach as we were
going to try qualify for this one people
weren't happy with what they thought was
growth they didn't see any growth that's
what they with jörgen claims be are
saying okay so he was so remember I'm
like why are we getting rid of this guy
yeah there was no reason together
expectations are like now we gotta win a
World Cup like guys what we did last
right yeah yeah it's like you're
competing with people who like when
these kids are like eight and they show
any kind of signs of being a good soccer
player yeah they go to like school they
that's their life now of course yeah
you're not gonna win like the u.s. would
have to go on like the ridiculous heater
to win a war we get worried about
feelings they lost they lost it like I
think Belgium was actually ranked number
one in the world when we lost to them in
the in in the World Cup
two to one like that's a respectable
that's as high
that's overachieving that's insane
that's like a crazy result and then
Renaldo's the really like this Chiana
Renaldo yeah yeah yeah when he did that
remember what we were beating them and
it was like yeah and then like we just
needed like it was like two minutes ago
and he did that amazing kick where the
guy did the header into the boom into
the goal oh yeah there was like a Steve
Nash pass
yeah who's so he put in the one place
where the guy had to be the only place
you going and that's why I'm like oh
there's levels there's definitely lows
yeah how great is it that Zoltan come
here just the bank like just to be in LA
yeah Beckham did it to remember when
there's a Beckham did it yeah it's smart
I didn't realize that he how old is that
guy I thought he was like young but I
guess he's deeper even huge like 30s
right I don't know I thought he was like
really young I'm like no it's just this
year Ibrahim a [ __ ] not David Beckham
not David Beckham oh the new guy Ibrahim
Alton's don't we - guy III guess he's
older than I thought because um I don't
know I mean you go to you go to LA to
like you know like if LeBron next year
goes to LA it's he doesn't care he I
mean if he does it's because he doesn't
care about bad they belong to mom
Philadelphia horse I do
Ibrahim of inches 36 by the way oh well
there you go 36 that's coming off like
our place become the like our league has
become be like the seniors tour yeah it
is it's like the retired Bellator yeah
yeah I mean he could probably still play
in the Premier League or in any of the
like the German league or anything like
[ __ ] it into my career I mean I'm not
started even yeah yeah but I mean maybe
he turned down a lot of money the clay
on shitty teams yes I'm saying he could
play on like other teams for sure in the
British League they would take him but
he'd rather play on the best team and be
in LA and just bang [ __ ] light-skinned
black strippers Yeah right with his [ __ ]
oh come on dude comes - don't suggest
doing with this car hey do you guys
watch any UFC fights this weekend I bet
on you did yeah I went to this website
you went
ts I bet the acai for all your betting
needs our good friends there our
longest-running sponsor they've been
with us for like what five years now
it's like forever and now we love them
bet DSi for all your bet needs just go
to Betty si.com use the promo code punch
25 and you'll get $25 betting cash and
then anything you deposited in the
deposit they'll double that they'll
double that BAM
so if I put a hundred in they'll give me
200 yeah I put about to do that I think
it's a bad business deal in their part I
think they'll lose money in the long run
seems like it what if I put a million in
the well you might be in to do that
couple is money yeah I mean that's a lot
of money that's a lot of couple people
bet million dollar bets on the Super
Bowl yeah all the time dude there's a
guy in Vegas who's famous for dropping
like insane cash hunch I think two guys
wives Floyd Mayweather well you see
Floyd tried to bet on his own fight
they're like no no that's not how
various it's not happy yeah yeah yeah if
that fight didn't go ten rounds ah Vegas
would be [ __ ] and they say the Vegas
is [ __ ] with the Golden Knights right
now if the Golden Knights win this
championship oh wow Vegas is in deep
[ __ ] they would have been a deep shade
of Conor McGregor and the odds were like
a [ __ ] bazillion to like one that
they win a championship yeah so everyone
in Vegas how they are people see those
odds they're like [ __ ] it I'll put a
hundred bucks on that [ __ ] that I'll do
that too dude and now they're gonna have
to pay out like a [ __ ] ton of money to
all those people that put a hundred
bucks
yeah that's Wow it's gonna be hilarious
anyways had these UFC fights that
happened this weekend and it was there
was a bunch of like Bellator was in go
they already happened they were both in
England wait they happen in the week or
the weekend and I see in my life till
vs. uh Wonder Boy and till came in
really really heavy I think he came in
like three pounds over and which is
happening a little bit now because the
fight
don't stress about I'll just be over
yeah and then they get the fight what
they're way bigger I mean you know this
was your almost definitely gonna win wow
you see it's even more now
I think this one he had to give up more
to make the fight happen but he's he's
visibly much bigger than this guy I mean
I was like dude this looks like a you
put a smaller guy this weird position
with it like yeah I don't want to fight
that come on man please you gotta make
this might happen but it's like the
rules are they can be like no I'm not
fighting he's coming over way they lose
their money yeah just uh so he made a
rule that he couldn't be this much over
cuz like everybody comes in to the
actual fight much heavier than they
weigh in sometimes twenty pounds over it
okay cuz that's whole thing starve
yourself get into this smaller weight so
you have the size advantage and then
come in huge in the fight and you better
tilt tilt with so be I was like holy
[ __ ] this guy's huge but it was that you
know tilt until knockdown Wonder Boy but
I felt they could go either way people
are saying that Wonder Boy got robbed
you know I don't know UFC and this is
p.m. thing I think it's a suicide note
for the for the UFC I think they're
gonna take me on ESPN now I think
they're gonna take away all of its
outlaw image yeah anytime UFC [ __ ] [ __ ]
up anytime you have sea fighter [ __ ]
up ESPN is gonna [ __ ] run it into the
ground you know I mean it's just
yeah yeah yeah no one's gonna be able to
make comments or tweets about how people
in the Obama administration look like
Planet of the Apes people right right
right this world coming to
they took the cash they took 1.5 billion
dollars yeah it's a lot of money it's a
lot of money I mean you said you would
kill 3,000 people for like three billion
dollars you remember when you said that
yeah I did remember what I said that's
it
re would you all cause 9/11 for three
billion dollars yeah much okay again for
three billion dollars re billion dollars
I did it just
so sure just to prove that you were
connected look at some sage look it is
about three billion dollars let's be
realistic anybody would do that it
already happened I wouldn't do it it
already happened no worse you [ __ ] up
and be busy knocking somebody's dents
out of their car local reference I'm
just saying all I'm just admitting that
for 3 billion dollars I will do pretty
much all any atrocity that you can
imagine would you cause the Holocaust
for three billion oh man here we go
that's here we don't think I would
create a holocaust somewhere I would
fund a holocaust small country you could
probably get a good Holocaust for a bill
in Chad I could save my money yeah I
feel like you could get a Holocaust for
way less they were happening for free
there's people if you're willing to buy
the flamethrowers there's definitely
yeah for the cost of a few thousand
flamethrowers we could have some
genocide re-listen going pretty strong
right now I want your triple it
yeah go even harder in the pain okay you
get you start getting your you start
getting your grafts out you're like look
you see this it looks good at this month
but look you kind of tape it off here
I need constant Danza I needed to go
like this all the way up here's the
population all the way up I don't want a
solution I wanna find a very quiet I'm
not Jason TiVo star what he walks I
would cut my own [ __ ] off for three
billion words I cut your [ __ ] off for
free I would slight I don't even [ __ ]
want it now would you eat it yes yes of
course I do cuz if I'm already gonna cut
it off I would definitely I would eat it
anyway because it's like it's already
off you gotta eat it you gotta eat it
we billion dollars even fitting this
little kind of [ __ ] you could buy for
three billion dollar definitely I would
take one billion and get the dope is
[ __ ]
top grade dude I would not you know got
to know you know what I would just get a
sex change at that point I just be a
woman with three billion dollars why
would you do that why not why would you
want to live as a 40 year old woman I'm
eccentric baby I'm rich what these four
three billion oh you're gonna be like a
[ __ ] you're gonna have both of them
maybe a dick and a [ __ ] I like that
and then I'm gonna buy an island I'm
gonna buy an island and to just invite
people to come there and then I'm gonna
kill him all I'm gonna create a genocide
you'd be like the Tesla of [ __ ] just
plugging it into yourself Oh
self pregnant you're just gonna you see
you see B USB port down there and yeah
and then just plug in all kinds of sex
toys just be [ __ ] terma [ __ ]
terminator [ __ ] man I'm ready dude
where's the three billion I'll do it I'm
hyped I'll do it on camera started go
fund me let's go so you know how they do
how do you rate tweets to get a twenty
bucks a Nuggets will do how many how
many dollars for diri to cut his penis
off I said penis for you I could have
said what number give me a number for
you to cut your dick I mean we're
starting we're starting at three billion
and we're working our way down clearly
it's closin no clearly fifty bucks
two hundred two hundred thousand oh dude
cuz you can get you know because you can
get no no no because you could get two
hundred the house in no [ __ ] way no
way I'm even thinking of even a million
even saying a million I can't say it
because you could possibly get a million
dollars like that's not even like that
much money yet and then it happen to
hear you dick offer not life-changing
money yeah you need light for a couple
group odds 30 million 30 million is like
that's life-changing money it's like I
play this gigantic [ __ ] plum you would
cut your dick off for thirty million
dollars I know that's crazy that's less
than my that's like that's like good
clothes or money for the wait Griffen
three years into this contract money
it's just so much money though thirty
million in cash it's a lot of money bro
I mean my dick is like it's only getting
worse you know
it's it's not getting better my life
with $30,000,000 is getting way better I
could go do everything I I would do it
thirty million that's like a lot of
money man I wish I was a billionaire I'd
hear this maybe there's a billionaire
out there dude this is gonna work my
life could change drastically from this
podcast I mean seriously if someone
seriously billionaires list in this
podcast another podcast if someone
seriously offer ibly thirty million
dollars and I went to a doctor and I
said hey could I legitimately cut my
[ __ ] off and and survive and there's
people I would do I would 100% I'd 99%
do it for thirty million dollars rate
kids like it where it gets like a like a
how much money a dark mirror off the
table it's not an option anymore
you've lost it took you long talking but
here's the new option fifty million
dollars take your [ __ ] out you know chop
it off whatever real humane you know get
showing doctor really take off and move
it on your forehead
you look like one of those like French
bulldogs like so you know your whole
dick and balls on your forehead so
you're like you're like your dildo
missing there's after you cut your dick
off there's nothing you could do to make
it worse you got you have the money it's
really just about me spending that money
yeah so okay I got my dick on my
forehead
I'm just when I get to Mount Everest
people are gonna be like oh yeah that's
that eccentric millionaire guy who cut
his dick off for 50 million check them
out it's only gonna make me more famous
to be honest you didn't I'll make more
money I'll go on all the TV shows you
know no I'll charge you have to blur
your forehead because yeah I I gotta
wear a special hat I gotta wear a
special hat out in public and after what
covered like a windsock home you'd have
to wear like a weird hat with like a bow
like underwear we'd have to wear like a
hairnet and there you go I'd make even
more money because I create a product
it's a beekeepers hat I create a product
exactly what you have to do I guess
sponsored by that product Hanes would
wear like you know what if it was
functional your dick on your head oh
thank you God get a hard-on and then I
make more money I'm in porn I mean crazy
porn where I'm just [ __ ] like just
bang
this head-butting from behind oh my god
that's amazing
oh you're like reverse cowgirl what Ari
what do you think his life expectancy
would be for a guy that could [ __ ]
[ __ ] chicks from his forehead well how
long do you think that life lives when
you're just banging strippers and porn
stars if you're in a very prone position
to violence you have to really be down
not know [ __ ] like Molly lift them up
and I'm so strong should I have to be so
sorry boys I'm up uhgh what I get
depressed would you get you think you
would get depressed without a [ __ ] uh if
you cut it off but you you get a certain
amount of oppression right oh [ __ ] now
that you're rich and all these hot
chicks wanna [ __ ] and you're like ah man
it's really [ __ ] Twilight Zone to me
that's weird what would you rather cut
your dick off or your feet off oh man
that's amazing question can I cut
everything off eat feet could you just
get fake feet how about your dick or
both your arms oh damn arms can I cut
off both my legs my dick and my arms and
my head is that an option yeah I don't
know what's happened on this show but
can I just cut can I just put me on a
butcher's thing just every two inches
chop chop chop chop Jack I'll do that
for 50 million dollar what about your
balls Missy would you rather have cut
off your balls or your ears can I just
replace them like I have balls for years
and years for balls I look up my balls
wait so here yeah you can hear without
your ears yeah you just look then I'll
go go eight years and has grown my hair
long there guy without ears
there's no cherry pea that would be into
that they're all like weird [ __ ] you'd
find some chick who's oh yeah yeah I
mean there's guys that like weird be
hard working one of them glasses dick
Colt your earhole [ __ ] and that was like
your fashion you never find out before
and now it's open to you yeah literally
I would cut my ears off and just grow my
hair long and keep my balls dude we've
really dug deep on this one yeah we
[ __ ] go dude why they love it man I
mean it's punch strong it's about sports
but it's also about
hot dogs in the butt and cutting your
balls off and stapling them to your face
and the amount of money you would take
to get your to go [ __ ] list for the rest
of your life which by the way might not
be that long you know I mean yeah people
you have 10 years yeah 10 years yeah I
could live 10 years without a [ __ ] for
30 or 40 or 50 million come on that's a
lot of fun creeping up on the age we're
gonna be living without a [ __ ] anyway I
know I'm saying it's already like kind
of like like I'm gonna be [ __ ]
everyone in my 60s it's like the
Japanese have have Robo dicks coming
right
they gotta be having Robo dicks coming
out soon definitely I mean well they
already have Robo dicks but are they
gonna have to attach them to us soon
what do you mean they already got Robo
dicks
if robot dicks just the mistake on the
machines on like pornhub or what oh yeah
yeah [ __ ] but not they that fits in
your [ __ ] cuz I mean they gotta put
them on us now [ __ ] yeah then that has
to exist those crazy fits some sort of
like belt or something that has to
already exist right yeah definitely but
I'm saying they're gonna like you know
we're gonna it's gonna be a part of us
it'll be the Japanese to the Japanese
100% their population is shrinking
writing that book write a book about if
I did it this is how I do it yeah he's
right he's writing an erotic he calls it
fiction about each one of the victims I
love it go out and a blazing going into
it to be super sexual yeah good I can't
wait to hear finally working dirty huh
yeah is that a lot of presents room at
Johnny look that up what I'm kidding
dude as Lucy Kay gone up yeah re are you
getting nervous we're almost halfway
through has Lucy K gone up yet no he's
not getting oh you guys have a bet about
when he'll go up now him and run as easy
dude I can't believe it's been how long
how long do you say what what's the date
yeah 1900 it's a close call because you
know Louis he doesn't need it you know I
mean he can just do it dude we don't put
out he needs to
end up comedy but he doesn't need the
money or the or the you know the
whatever it's called out the credit not
the credibility he doesn't either the
action in his life he's probably happy
to just like I just feel bad for a
little we don't pull out that many
special you don't put up yeah yeah yeah
you don't put out that many special to
not want to go up dude are you
approximately 210 days left well we all
know he's definitely gonna come back at
some point let's go dude do you know
anybody you guys gotta know each other
go go up I don't want to do gay porn oh
well what's that what's that what's the
payoff gay porn you have to reenact you
have to read you have to reenact the gay
porn script the winner gets to write a
gay porn script like free of like a
scene yeah that you have to perform the
best of your ability
3 page 3 page with another male actor or
what yeah well whatever it could be a
dog could be why did he agree to that
why wouldn't he Wow this is a this goes
so you know Sam was like hey after the
hot dogs in the butt where do you go
from there and I think you guys have
answered the question there yeah
someone's here to get [ __ ] in the ass
at some point probably by your robot I
think there's no sex but there could be
a makeout I think that was the no sex no
sex there is a it could be kissing yes
yeah kissing kissing we don't have to be
in it no dick touching though they are
I'm saying whoever loses when they write
the script you can't be like oh no he's
getting [ __ ] in the ass oh no sounds a
makeout scene there's a makeout scene
and it's very sexual like like if it
went to page 4 you know we're gonna head
walking and and then he could make it he
could have to like kiss down the neck
and then yeah that kind of [ __ ] yes the
nipples
uh-huh and then who are they gonna cast
who are the actors that you're gonna get
like just gay actor I'll be an extra or
if it's got sag voucher I'll do it I'll
be in it
do I get to suck a [ __ ] or saw mine off
what kind of craft services you're gonna
have there are you doing with this
salami why you nip what are you doing
pick listen he's picking the skin off
that that the look it's like a little
yeah see it's like oh what's that calm
like the skin you know what do you never
he kept around here yeah a wrapper the
casing there it is there it goes
come on man you let us down yeah speed
it up yeah a lot people like this you
should go on Twitch and do this all day
you'll get a lot of followers put the
whole goddamn thing in your mouth for
patreon people just like you know real
IRL experience in real life Ari Shaffir
eating pepperoni
you'll get followers by the way if you
were Instagram model you'd have 5,000
people watching you do that you have no
real job they don't wild they're
literally like it's hooker mentality
they buy all their fans I mean it's like
hilarious what a boring insane how long
can that go on for I can't go on forever
cuz it's like it's a dime a dozen people
love hot chicks oh I know I mean there's
always gonna be the cream of the crop
you know the top 1% but I mean you can't
get into that game now right it's just
too close I think if you showed up as a
hot chick you'd be in the game okay
there's never enough hot chicks now
there's never enough hot once you cut
your dick off you can [ __ ] [ __ ]
clean it up I'm not that young though
you know I can't hang mm-hmm
I smell you on that alright have you
been practicing basketball we're gonna
we're gonna up to [ __ ] and really focus
all your tickets yet no I mean to have
you know badly hurt me but I wanted to
get out there and actually play today
and what stopped you
oh my god yeah I could see that huh
maybe in your contract you're not
allowed to eat butter popcorn most
athletes aren't allowed the hot buttered
popcorn for that very reason even though
they have tried to cheat kill Tony tried
to cheat yeah I could see it already
happening oh these other comics are on
our show and they like played Cosmo I'm
like okay cool then we got Pollard and
we got you know a bunch of people til so
it's gonna be Tony Josh and Watkins
Watkins they got lucky not getting red
band in there actually on three yeah I
saw
they want I don't care I told him red
band should dress like a 70s coach
player there should be some I'm gonna
put this out guys
who is it who in there three Watkins
Tony and who and giant Marv
alright Martin here you guys if you
place in the first round you can add red
band full on three you still have no
chance against us no because if we're
gonna have to stop the game for a full
fledge heart attack on your ribbon when
it's to it nothing red bands gonna have
a [ __ ] full-on heart attack in the
middle of the [ __ ] no way all this
dude no layups
is it a tournament with other bunch of
pot how many podcast for four for us
Legion of skanks kill Tony and come town
I think I think it's between I come town
I should we view should we be worried
Ari no only only skanks we should be
worried about who's a big J so who we
was covering nerd who's the third
Anthony oh yeah that's right yeah
I mean I was gonna say I'll cover BJ but
I have more of a wingspan I think Sam
now you're the fattest one you should be
gorgeous I'm big on big big on big I'm
not against that that's less running for
you whereas I disrupt three as you know
very well Sam i disrupt three-point
shooters with my long reach when's it
happening when is this basketball toward
middle of July in Brooklyn oh [ __ ]
during the shank fest comedy festival
middle is warming out so get your
tickets now at re-shared icon slash gang
fest for all yours get him today go to
today Oh what else what else
han Solo Seiki tickets if you want and
United Southwest Lou aye sir Brent
Spirit Airlines
could not be cheaper I mean they're just
I mean they
take took out Springs out of their seats
so you can't recline it's like what are
you doing it is what it is you just as
they had oh they got flights like that
out in Europe I always take them there
like it's like for 20 euros you can fly
like anywhere and people are always
complaining like that you never look at
all the coop you can only bring like a
ziplock bag as like it's like just it's
20 euros you know just deal with it
just get on there it's like getting on a
bus you know you just deal with it it
sucks but it's not yeah it's a sky boss
man you just [ __ ] get on there and it
smells like a [ __ ] Burning Man
festival European techno festival and
people are still half the people around
sunglasses still jacked up from the
night before it's hilarious alright now
you're what first of all you're eating a
box of chocolate yeah many pepperonis
and now you have a [ __ ] caramel
sucker a box of lollipops mm-hmm the
original C's I'm hungry too man where's
the food around here
oh crap sirs having Nick any of you guys
seen the Steve Martin and Martin Short
no but I want to excellent of course -
amazing this guy is fantastic and when
you factor they're both in their 70s
it's so [ __ ] funny
no it means nothing Steve Martin does
nothing half-assed his blue I mean grass
albums are [ __ ] amazing band plays on
yeah Martin Short is so [ __ ] either
it Sam it's really great there LeAnn our
Karen oh by the way they're from a
different era comedy where comedy all
had to be good you know painting you
know now you can talk for an hour it's
so bad now and all of it but you know
some well I mean like some people are
trying to pass off your life's weekend
was um this weekend was I
amateur weekend at The Comedy Store
packed but it's like Amateur Night right
so it's like it's Memorial Day weekend
everybody and the crowds the crowds they
were just like superset well I mean or
was great the main room I'm talking
about the crowds when you say amateur
now you're not talking about the
comedian no no it sounded like you were
talking about problem
you know the lineups are great well I
guess you talk about the crowds yeah
yeah really is it like that's a good
point that like that they were they had
to do it when it mattered because so
much yeah in watching this it really
dawned on me how much comedy now is like
people screaming their opinions and
trying to be controversial and trying to
fight you know to me I think it's I
think it's just like everybody going up
there doing cookie cutter bullseye but
but but oh you think comedies about
people screaming they're a big when you
when you look at it's like people it's
like it's everybody going I think
there's a believe this here's my opinion
on this I think this that's what it is
and then when you watch this it's not a
show yeah it's in comedy this shows that
those guys worked on we're just that
everything was made differently they
even shot on film so you you had to go
through table reads and run throughs and
a lot of act a lot of practice or
whatever it's called you know like
rehearsals a lot of rehearsals
everything had to be dialed in kind of
like show business style and nowadays
it's just like we'll take it from a
different angle we'll pick it up here
even in your special you can cut
everything kind of together you can do
five nights and cut it all together I
mean yeah I don't think you had a long
show tight and everything lined and they
tell hilarious stories they roast the
[ __ ] out of each other it's really funny
I mean those guys are yeah I thought
that came out like I read an article
about this well I'm literally cried
laughing maybe three or four times in an
hour
Steve Martin's book is one of the best
oh yeah and a born Stan I think oceans
hate does I think I think they're
showing how women can be in male
comedies but it's like just think women
comedies yeah just make women comedy or
a group that's not your group we don't
go that way we do it too
yeah well they're just gonna complain
that it's sexism if it doesn't do well I
just don't understand like a good movie
I don't care for men or women or not in
it make a [ __ ] good movie I guess
there's no like the only thing that
because Hollywood is so built on like
following these like you know cookie
cutter ideas you know one two three four
five save the cat [ __ ] that it's
like it's hard to make a woman comedy
because comedies are based on the
failures of men's relate
and chips the failures of men being dads
imagine it what like bad mom are you
gonna make a movie about a bad mom maybe
but it's not that funny you know it's
not as funny as a bad dad I don't know
maybe I'm wrong I could be wrong but
here's my problem when you go we're
gonna make us all female anything and
it's not to have a problem to being all
female but if that's the jumping-off
point it's like when somebody writes a
sketch about something and it's because
they have a funny joke and they want
rice sketch around that joke ya ever
worked yeah if you're if you're starting
off is we're gonna do all female this
yeah then you're already you're already
kind of beautiful oh this is really
finally Seuss I do we can maybe make it
all female then it's a different thing I
think they should just focus on female
writers I mean they can write male
characters or female care just get more
females involved in movies the problem
is this when guys see an all-female
something they know it's just gonna be
man bashing like we've been watching
this for the last 20 years in
commercials like dad can't wipe his own
ass without mom showing him how to do it
that's like every [ __ ] commercial
think about all the situations where
it's all women anything in real life it
just doesn't happen as much as all men
right they're wrong am I wrong help me
out here I mean no bowling night guys
and they can't right have to have their
fathers and mothers right for them and
so then they just pass on and it's not
like I'm not in touch because that
they're untalented across the board
possible across the board there's no
good one it to being attractive for too
long and now it's becoming obvious what
it's like oh you want a [ __ ] lead
role and great you were just the
autistic kid we're letting shoot some
threes one game but if you actually want
to start on a regular game well so what
will happen I don't read a lot I don't
read a lot of the news or I don't keep
up on current [ __ ] but took best of my
knowledge the last woman that mattered
and did something good Helen Keller
since then it's been downhill for these
[ __ ] hey I don't know dude I'm not
going to see oceans eight because it's
not cuz it's all women it's just I'm
tired I see one was on them and oceans
twelve suck dick so it's my first one
was weak compared to like I don't know
man you know wake they just don't make
good movies anymore I'm old man get off
my lawn when they had Julia Roberts
playing a role and the plot which was
that she looks like Julia Roberts so
we're gonna run with that right I'm like
you guys just ran out of ideas I'm gonna
definitely watch the Manson movie a
hundred percent that sounds [ __ ] good
[Music]
yeah good man movie yeah I'm making a
woman sin movie they should make a
woman's all woman's cast of the Manson
movie that would be good
actually they could from the who are the
chicks that actually did the killing
that like Selena Gomez play Charles
Manson who are the chicks that [ __ ]
Manson they could do a movie about that
Sharon Tate was that was that it was no
that's who they were right guys that's
our show David dearie tell them one more
time about your your podcast a podcast
where I solve people's problems you
could send me your problem to ask David
Erie at gmail.com I will solve it de ER
why I got it and it's called mother
podcast
Keep Calm see ticketing needs for David
I will give you 78 percent off of a seat
on my podcast just type in the code
punch drunk a [ __ ] punch [ __ ] too much
[ __ ] on this much [ __ ] guys you're the
best things called
MF problem solving with David Erie an
executive producer Sam Tripoli we love
you guys thanks for all the love on the
internet and if you're sick if you're a
sick kid don't forget come to my March a
dime bag sting in Long Beach I'll sell
you pot if you're under 10 if you got
come make sure to come true dude it's
just